did spider-man make an unapproved cameo
in the x-men animated series ever wonder
how popular the show was when it first
premiered this is the untold truth of
x-men the animated series
in the 1980s margaret lesch was working
as a producer in tv animation helping to
get shows like gi joe and muppet babies
on the air but she still couldn't get
her passion project off the ground a
cartoon adaptation of marvel's x-men
comics while working at hanna-barbera
lesh met stan lee marvel's prolific
creator and company face and pitched him
on an x-men show she recalled telling
lee in the book previously on x-men it's
really about a group of disenfranchised
teenagers and a lot of teenagers feel
that way so why wouldn't this be a hit
with the kids
lee was convinced and the two then set
out to pitch the x-men show alas abc nbc
and cbs all passed lesh had all but
given up until a fourth broadcast
network emerged
she eventually became head of fox kids
the division of the fox network
responsible for its saturday morning
lineup so in her new position she
commissioned an x-men series in 1992.
the creative staff for x-men the
animated series came together in early
1992 with fox looking to premiere the
series in the fall of that year
considering the long production lead
times required for animation showrunner
eric lewald's team had mere weeks to
come up with a series bible which is a
20 to 100 page document outlining the
show's world characters and aims lee
wald basically had to figure out the
entire series in that short period and
it didn't help that he wasn't intimately
familiar with the x-men comic books
a first step toward acquainting himself
and his team with the mutant superheroes
would be to acquire as many x-men back
issues as possible but that proved
difficult the title was relatively
obscure and leewald had to make do with
whatever source material he could find
he procured it all in a haphazard way
buying up old anthologies borrowing
issues from friends and getting marvel
comics to black and white photocopy old
issues and mail them most of the show
bible was even heavily influenced by the
x-men board game the uncanny x-men
special campaign set which included
character descriptions a map of the
x-mansion and the official handbook of
the marvel universe
while the look and feel of x-men the
animated series comes from the post-1975
reboot of the comic series eric leewald
didn't directly adapt old issues that's
in part because a comic book's method of
storytelling is significantly different
from that of a tv show as leewald
explained to blast from the past in 2007
time the actual action in a book and you
get about 3 minutes longer arcs from the
comics were a better fit for adaptation
but as leewald noted there we had to
deal with the various secondary plots
that weave in and out of the main story
some of those plots worked for a
children's cartoon while others didn't
as leewald put it if you were to compare
the actual dark phoenix books to the
animation story i'd wager that about 50
percent of the original was trimmed away
furthermore leewald's team couldn't just
take old material and animate it because
the public at large wasn't terribly
familiar with the vagaries of the
franchise as seywald told comics beat in
2017 when we started we were telling
stories primarily for people unfamiliar
with the x-men world no one knows who
will be a mutant at birth
we discover our extraordinary powers at
about your age x-men the animated series
features a massive cast of characters in
addition to those who enjoyed regular
appearances many more mutants arrived
for cameos one offs or two populate
finite story arcs and then disappear
thereafter deciding what mutants from
the comics to use as the main characters
was especially challenging for the
cartoon's developers marvel helped the
show's writers determine which of them
were must-haves such as professor x
cyclops wolverine and jean grey but as
eric leeward told blast from the past
beyond that any out of a couple dozen
major mutants could have filled out the
rest of the core leewald and his team
decided on storm because her ability to
control the weather would translate well
in a visual medium like tv
rogue was picked because her inability
to be touched offered an emotionally
compelling characteristic plus her
strength and flight would work well in
fight sequences additionally lee wald
knew that the show needed a juvenile
character and marvel reps liked jubilee
more than other young mutants and then
morph based on a relatively obscure
comic character named changeling was
added for the specific purpose of having
a sympathetic friend of wolverine who
would be killed early on this one
fox ordered x-men in february of 1992
and wanted to debut it that fall a
rather daunting prospect but somehow
eric leewald and company were ready for
their premiere date and x-men the
animated series debuted on fox on
october 31st 1992 with the episode
knight of the sentinels part one fox was
so confident in the series and wanted to
give it as big of a launch as possible
that it aired the initial episode at
seven o'clock pm the series then moved
to its regular saturday morning time
slot albeit sporadically night of the
sentinels part 2 aired on november 7th
but then the quickly building audience
was left without a new episode for three
weeks and then the next new installments
didn't air until late january according
to lewald the gap was because of
animation problems which took months to
fix this led to major production delays
but once the show got going with regular
airings ratings soared and x-men became
one of the biggest hits in saturday
morning history as many as 8 million
homes tuned in and some weeks it would
attract more viewers than the
competition on abc cbs and nbc combined
x-men the animated series marks a
watershed moment in both comic
adaptations and saturday morning
cartoons it was one of the first shows
to present marvel comics characters and
stories in a serious and dramatic way
and it was also one of the few kids
cartoons that was serialized making such
an ambitious series would require a very
special cast of voice actors and x-men
producers found them though not right
away the casting and voice directors who
were used to wacky saturday morning
cartoons didn't understand the show's
vibe so they hired actors who did a lot
of silly broad voices as eric lewald
told the hollywood reporter in 2017 we
tried to convey to them what was
different about x-men and they didn't
hear it they thought they want to do
something goofy and childish the initial
recordings were so bad that the crew had
to throw everything out and start over
the voice team worked out of canada and
recruited veterans of the toronto
entertainment world including allison
court as jubilee and cal dodd as
wolverine interestingly enough those two
already knew each other is the child all
right not for long
they were fighting and i wanted to help
him and boom
for many marvel fans cal dodd's
portrayal of wolverine on x-men the
animated series is the definitive take
on the clawed and conflicted canadian
mutant dodd pulled from a number of
disperet sources to get the voice just
right during an audition a casting
director told him to emulate tough guy
actor steve mcqueen because wolverine is
similarly introspective and quiet as
dodd recalled to the hollywood reporter
he also threw clint eastwood and western
star ward bond into the mix meanwhile
wolverine's scrappiness came straight
from dodd who is a canadian as well as
he revealed to the hollywood reporter i
had grown up in a small town with many
fights i had seen these kinds of guys so
i threw in a bit of raspy voiced dj
wolfman jack dodd is proud of his work
and how it affected the viewers
including one in particular an
overweight bullied and depressed fan
sent a letter in which he revealed that
he had considered suicide but as dodd
recalled he was so in love with the
x-men saturday morning cartoon and
wolverine he was about to jump off his
roof but then he said i can't do this
i'm going to miss the saturday morning
x-men episode that's the kind of impact
it had on kids you called me friend
one of the most memorable elements of
x-men the animated series is its opening
sequence while character identifying
clips and scenes of mutant battles fly
by at frenetic pace the soundtrack
offers a suitably high energy theme song
built around a speedy ominous and
totally catchy hard rock guitar riff and
let's not forget those attention
attention-grabbing keyboard stabs the
theme song has brought a lot of joy to a
lot of people even independently of the
series as amateur cover versions are all
over youtube but it wasn't such a lovely
experience actually making the song
according to composer ron wasserman he
wrote several songs for x-men producer
saban entertainment in the 90s including
the theme for mighty morphin power
rangers wasserman claims that the
company cut him off from talking to
anyone at marvel or fox about how the
song should sound fearing that they'd
poach him for higher profile composing
work nevertheless representatives of
saban were very hands-on and critical as
wasserman told inverse in 2016
x-men was just a boatload of work
because there was a lot of involvement a
lot of let's tweak this make this bigger
redo this we ended up with 80 or 90
tracks for that thing they just kept
trying to get more and more energy out
of it
superheroes popping up in movies and tv
shows about other characters is an
almost mundane phenomena in the 21st
century for example thor ragnarok
heavily involved the hulk spider-man was
a major part of captain america civil
war and dozens of comic book legends all
converged together in avengers end game
but back in the early 90s shared movie
and or tv universes weren't a matter of
course especially since the rights to
different characters created by the same
publishing entity had been sold to
several different studios and production
companies nevertheless x-men the
animated series dabbled in crossovers
and universe sharing even though doing
so could violate copyrights and
contracts as a show artist and
self-proclaimed treasure hider larry
houston revealed to the hollywood
reporter in 2017 some of my favorite
easter eggs were the unexpected ones
that i added for the fans like doctor
strange deadpool the black panther all
of whom are now superstars in their own
feature films i never added cameos if it
distracted from the main story
higher-ups heard that houston had added
spider-man to a scene and ordered it
deleted so as he recalled i had to sneak
him into another episode but it was just
an arm shooting webbing to save someone
off camera from falling debris
obviously x-men the animated series is
based on marvel's various and
long-running x-men comic book series but
the show proved so popular that it ended
up also being influential in the
development of the franchise in the
other direction over time things
introduced by the show's writers were
integrated into the comics making them
canonical to the x-men universe the
1995-1996 x-men comics crossover event
age of apocalypse was directly inspired
by the x-men the animated series
two-part episode one man's worth the
premise focused on a time-hopping
alternate history adventure in which
characters go back in time to kill
professor x thereby altering the present
and sending several x-men into the
future eric sewald conceived the idea
but it came to him from media outside
the x-men universe as he told comics
beat in 2017 most good stories have been
told many times in many different forms
i borrowed from it's a wonderful life
and the star trek episode city on the
edge of forever for the central idea
what would the world have been like
without this one crucial man
it's incredible how one kid could mean
so much to so many people
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]